speaking of propaganda i think while the
media establishment
are doing a good job for the dems biden
himself not doing a great job
biden has a message now okay it's a
message
about how to break out of the lockdowns
and the message is simple
vax or mask it's waxed
or masked that's it that's the whole
video faxed
or masked is that does that rhyme
no no it's it's actually it's like a
almost a near rhyme so it's even
kind of weirder and more annoying what
does that mean vaxxed or masked i'm
neither right now and i feel great
i've been neither for the whole time and
i i feel awesome
this reminds me of when puff daddy did
that stupid voter die thing
say vote or die you got vote
or die um
i'm pretty sure there's a third option
unless you're unless this is a criminal
threat
i what if i just do neither what if i
just hang out is that cool
vaxxed or mask or die or vote
no not not very persuasive not
persuading a whole lot of americans
by the way by the way our other
propaganda minister here in the united
states dr
fauci has come out and admitted once
again
that he lied admitted once again that he
misled the american people
remember we were told you by dr fauci
you have to wear the masks
even after you're vaccinated you have to
do it you say well what
what's the point of getting the vaccine
if i have to wear the masks after no you
have to
and then they realized no one was going
to get the vaccine because if your
life's not going to change why would i
shoot myself full of this
hastily developed inoculation if i don't
even get any
if i don't get any political benefit for
it and he says okay actually you can
take the mask off
you just ask well what happened here he
said well it's basically political
theater
i'm obviously careful because i mean i'm
a physician and a healthcare provider i
am now much more comfortable in
in people seeing me indoors without a
mask i mean
before the cdc made the recommendation
change
i didn't want to look like i was giving
mixed signals but being a fully
vaccinated person
the chances of my getting infected in an
indoor setting is extremely low and
that's the reason why in indoor settings
now
i feel comfortable about not wearing a
mask because i'm fully man i'm fully
vaccinated
yes i wore the mask and also told all
you stupid sheep to wear the mask
even though i knew you didn't have to
and it was total nonsense
because i wanted to shill for the cdc
because i'm a doctor i'm a doctor when
was the last time dr fauci saw a patient
how many patients does this guy see a
week he's not a doctor he's a politician
who has medical expertise but he's a
politician
political theater so if he's thrown away
his credibility
why should we believe him why should we
follow these guys
the associated press paling around with
terrorists
why should we listen to them the
leftists on cnn are arguing against
positions that we do not hold in
very often just spreading outright lies
like don lemon did on
critical race theory why should we
listen to them why do they have any
authority leftist politicians claire
mccaskill
saying that we just want to punish rape
victims or something why do we listen to
this what
we have no obligation to engage in a bad
faith
debate we have no obligation to pay any
heed to people
who have acknowledged their own bad
faith and squandered their credibility
like the fouches of the world and the
other technocrats none i know
there's something about the conservative
movement quote unquote of the last 20
years where you think no we just
we've got the free marketplace of ideas
and we've got to engage in the ideas
we'll always win no we have no
there's no reason whatsoever to deal on
the level with people who are acting in
bad faith
not a chance of show me the good faith
argument please show me one
and i'd love to engage with it but other
than that if assuming you can't
we need to exercise our political power
if you don't ring that bell right now
you are a racist you are a sexist
and you are endangering hundreds of
millions of americans
am i doing that right i'm trying to be
as persuasive as the mainstream media
are
well that's it you gotta subscribe you
gotta like that's how you'll get
notifications otherwise you're you'll be
the worst person in the world and listen
to me and listen to me
all right enough of my don lemon
subscribe we'll see you next time
you